hey guys I'm Ryan Wright I'm gonna be
reviewing the trailer today the red bag
trailer for a film called Everly it's
the red band international trailer I
don't know what the [ __ ] this is Salma
Hayek's Annette Merrill where the [ __ ]
she's been touching herself or something
let's watch this
you betrayed me
my men are already there you will die
that room tonight
with no way out the scene so I can give
you enough money for you to disappear
tonight
mom I cannot get out of here so if
you're gonna have to come to me oh damn
the movie looks interesting it looks fun
I'm not entirely sure how to feel about
it like as much as I want to say like oh
it's just gonna be one badass good time
I feel like there are flaws with it that
I can already pick up from on the
trailer this could just be the trailer
but you know I mean start off with some
hayek looks great that opening shot of
her where she was just in the bathroom
and whoever she's talking with the bad
guy on the phone Salma Hayek sounds like
she's probably a criminal I'm not sure
like it does make me want to know more
and then when she starts shooting up
those guys like it was stylish and it
was cool like this trailer from the
action scenes kept going back and forth
for me for that was pretty stylish and
awesome too well that looks a little
amateur I mean the shot from
first-person point of view where it's
panning around the room and it's killing
all those guys and some of those guys
render underwear and just shooting them
all like was pretty neat some of the
action seems derivative of something
like you might see in like a Tarantino
film when Tarantino's action is
derivative of something else all the
time but like it reminded me of like
what it looked like when people got shot
in Django Unchained like this film to me
looks like a cross between Kill Bill
diehard and well the raid was like die
hard but the fact that there's a bunch
of Asian people and makes me
automatically think of the rage now it
looks like a combination of things I
already liked like it has that Kill Bill
by by having it be a lead female and I
like the die hard thing about it where
she's like just in this room you know
she's in this apartment building and I
think that's really neat I mean it looks
like it takes place in real time so if
it does do that I mean that that would
be pretty [ __ ] interesting to watch
here's my honest opinion this set up and
the execution looks like it could be
something very unique as well as paint
homage to a lot of things but something
about it every now and again seem like
very b-movie ish but then that b-movie
ish vibe like really worked for it at
the same time some of it kind of rising
in John wick a little bit man I don't
know what it is but there's something so
hot about
my new to murder people in movies like
even if she's playing a full-blown
serial killer you're like Salma Hayek
you know [ __ ] she's hot as hell like
still for like a I don't know in
Hollywood years she's like 78 but I want
to know exactly what's going on with
where she keeps saying her mom has to
get out like I like a film that starts
off like BAM we're in the middle of
something and there's a bunch of [ __ ]
that happened before and now here's
what's about to happen like rather than
showing us everything that took place
before the moment we're starting we're
just throwing you into it in the middle
and then you know the rest is kind of
like a mystery of what happened before
and it unveils itself so I'm not sure
why the mom is so involved you never
really see it I know I want to know
something like a hitman or something she
must be or maybe she is a cop but it's
cool to see samehada doing this I like
you know I remember she came onto the
scene with desperado
and she did a little bit of action and
once upon a time in Mexico for some
reason none of her other films are
coming up in mind right now Wild West if
there's an actress out there who can
pull off badass action lead it's
definitely her she's one of the few some
of you women need to toughen up grow a
ball here or there I think this film
could really work if more than just
being badass action and and you know
exploitive violence if there's real
tension to it you know that's what I
didn't really get from this I didn't
really feel the suspense but if the
suspense is there when I'm watching the
film then yeah which is probably gonna
be a Rock'em Sock'em good time anyway
guys thanks for recommending that
trailer if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the reel rejects where
we're so badass that week Joe Lynch
that's the director and he directed
Knights of Badassdom oh I have the
[ __ ] movie buff now I'm gonna be
continuing shout out so go to
facebook.com slash the real reject
shoutouts where you can earn yourself a
shout-out by saying something
interesting
you